hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work okay we're all calm down from our
previous episode and I believe we're in
some sort of mansion here something like
that it's locked
big surprise okay going in here whoo
nice dining room and anything important
coming in the fireplace I know
immediately that they're gonna be hiding
stuff from a somebody's bad painting Oh
No
so I'm trying to be proactive because
these guys think outside the box I need
to think inside the box to counteract
another dining room how do you need two
dining rooms how many people are you
entertaining it all right dark in here
what what's this looks just all oh I
thought for sure that was gonna be some
weight it's a tiny painting of course
it's gonna be something damn it
okay I think it here here no no no no
you can say boy ole come on
I go go away hate you so much
openopenopen
nothing absolutely Oh what's this nope
okay never mind
I didn't even need to light that light
I'm in and out nothing that I need
anything down here somehow the windows
total blackness this Manor is floating
in the middle of space all right
anything in here can I hurry our lest I
be searching for all my years I did
actually I actually just before this I
got done finishing while watching the
extended version of Lord of the Rings
which I never got a chance to look at
before
okay no cool books and that always
brings it here in my eye when I finish
the trilogy very very good trilogy I
love it love love love love love love
okay anyway that's a whole side note
nothing did it win it I just kid I
picked up something great oh yeah East
Wing key gaah oh got distracted by stuff
okay I found a key that's probably
important to probably unlocks that
locked door unless that is the West Wing
hahaha oh I'm just about to run out
thank you so much I know this game
doesn't give me very much oil but at
least when it does
well actually I've got nothing good to
say about it giving me all haha
but wait a minute he's swanky wait I've
got to ace Winkies huh this game is like
duplicating everything and I have no
idea why smash your [ __ ] whoever owns
this place I don't really remember it
probably told me before Oh No
maybe probably typo one locks this door
the other locks the other door it locked
let me guess
okay how about the other one what hey
whoa where my hand go I can't even touch
store now [ __ ] why do I know okay ha
[Music]
what hello this is weird um okay as my
mind officially started to unravel
probably probably wait a minute there's
nothing here
wait there's nothing here what am i
doing there anyway to go into the foot
nah there's nothing here wait a minute
[Music]
wait maybe if I shut the door and then I
go out to the end or and I come back
what doesn't make any sense at all
music changed drastically what's going
on
wait a minute huh that's not a door oh
it is a door okay I thought it was
there's a different door what is going
on this this way lead to something else
what I don't even I'm so confused right
now
come on dance on your table huh now
break your [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] um was
there anything there had to be something
out here that I needed right had to be
right nothing this is obviously the
force that I was in before ah why I
didn't see anything else in the other
rooms and whoa hey why a minute I have
two keys ah wait a minute
wait a minute this is wait a minute this
is exactly the same wait a minute yeah
ah 20th of April 1822 Jane and I are
worn the [ __ ] holy have most of the
western wing has collapsed am i back in
Middleburg castle in the past did I
time-travel what it's going I can't move
this sure Oh why'd I did wha what that
is so cool I didn't know you could even
do that in amnesia yes
that is so cool sorry I heard it fired
annoy house like the coolest thing I've
ever seen in my life the balls a beer
okay nothing nothing is there anything
in here there wasn't anything in the
other world I was in well what the hell
what then still didn't help me what the
hell
Harun let me go back to the other one
let me try another key padlock key now
can I use it this way I do that the
forest opens up what happens if I do it
from the inside key won't work from this
side key won't work from this side man
that's some really cool stuff but I
don't know what I'm doing I don't know
what to do about that doesn't seem to be
anything here maybe there is something
here and I'm just not able to pick it
out what there's got to be something
can't just be a whole lot of nothing I'm
about to run out of oil on it piss
what's with these rocks are these rocks
leading to something else maybe
something over here something on the
ground I don't see anything it's just
like I mean this is really cool but I
mean why why this is the other key oh
man I don't know how they do that but
that is like so cool
I wish I knew what it could do what does
it mean
what does he mean breathe there's this
one like open now goes somewhere else
no too confused no I'm so confused this
is so weird cuz there were like another
key somewhere hidden on this bookshelf
maybe a third East Wing key that I got
to find probably hand and they look up
here there might be I mean if they're
those were this one in this bookshelf
was kind of hard to find maybe there's a
third one under one of the dinner plates
in the dining room maybe who knows could
be I think I checked all the paintings
[ __ ] yo [ __ ] [ __ ] like I give up
[ __ ] it's like a duplicate plate haha
okay so so far so nothing I didn't see
any keys go flying nothing on the chairs
nothing in there oh man that's gotta be
it I I'm thinking that's gotta be it
it's got to be like a third key that's
really well-hidden oh man where are you
where are yo it's gotta be behind a
painting that's like the most obvious
place I'm a I'm a jump cut cuz this
might take a while oh lordy ah ah ha
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah last key ah I knew
it had to be behind a painting that's
like the most obvious place okay so here
we go is this the right one yeah this
one kinda seems ominous this one is the
only one that's not really familiar to
me
uh haha another key Wow maybe this key
will work from this side
he won't work from this side okay
daddies look this is like okay I do
recognize this one this is where the
potent amor POTUS oh this is so cool is
that ha ha ah who's like the coolest
thing I've ever seen whoa hartleb had
never come to help him that bastard and
now his only safe place is gone along
with his only shard it was only one one
place left to go now back to this circle
okay oh man that read I cancel the dick
punching party because that was
unbelievable I was amazing
oh so amazing okay um does I mean that
this is fragile and I can break that
window now
oh hey Alexander how you do no I don't
know where you think you're going
obviously I'm losing my mind cuz I got
keys to portal dimensions in my pocket
wall I hate that picture that's like I
don't know why but that's it oh okay he
saw he heard that I was insulting him
and I'm about to run out of oil again
somebody you're not as ugly as him okay
don't look like there's anything here
some there no okay I need to find
something to throw out the window is
there a chair in here yes there is whoa
wait a minute
wow that took me a second to realize
that things changed I'll say wait that
this was all disorganized and now it's
nice sorry folks I'm a little slow when
it comes to those things just like I'm a
little slow and it comes to everything
in my life if you know what I mean
all right so that happened let me get
this chair again that was my original
plan throw it at the window see what
happens
Callaway broom I need this closet like
now like now [ __ ] off [ __ ] off and die
ha ha ha
Oh God and die where the hell did he
come from
Oh bull a bull your bull buddy you're an
a-hole
okay was he stuck on the window I think
he might have been stuck on that window
you didn't hear anything
[Music]
[ __ ] poo firs man [ __ ] you and your
door okay I'm going outside fine man
that's custom story this custom story
Jaime and I tell you I tells you I tells
you hello shovel Bao oh it's already um
rooked anyway was good for it it broke
itself before I got to it yeah that's
right uh-huh yeah whoever they are I
don't know who these like how or how I
know who they're but I don't know how
these voices got in my head like this
just seems nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope no no nope nope nope nope nope
nope no no I'm no p'n the [ __ ] out of
here nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope alright fine I didn't expect that
door to actually go anywhere
gurgling howls in pain own huh I know
that shuffle that was in the new monster
the shadow roared rawrr I'm an hour
markiplier you think you can mess with
me you oh no you're not okay enough
silliness let's just get on up business
ah piss that's back to done broke
goodness is there gonna be another
[ __ ] that's how this is gonna work no
okay good you know it was good for you
[Music]
okay that's what I thought
now you can go screw yourself and die
I'm sorry I should stop insulting people
and they're not around me because they
do not like to be insult Ted and they do
not like to be the butt of jokes okay
there's nothing in here I just wasted
oil again all right let's see what you
got buddy see what you got brah
Oh what up wait a minute let's don't
seem right something seems wrong
something very wrong what's going on
here what the hell wait wait what how
but that doesn't make any sense that
doesn't make any sense
how the what I don't even maybe I
screwed some up when I nope the [ __ ] out
but what what's going on here Oh No what
did i do did I break the game I probably
broke the game I bet I did
that's still locked and now this way is
blocked all right I probably didn't
break the game let's just kind of go our
way back I want to see if see if I'm
actually supposed to go some way before
I shut down all operations I didn't get
anything
I think anything I might have worked the
game I'm out of upset some triggers I'm
out of work too just a bit too much
alright anyway so I'm all out of time
anyway this game is getting wonky like
nobody's business so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done they're
working and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]
guy lady haircut is out of style